欢迎各位收听今天这期摆车悬说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们聊两个话题。
一个就是马上拉地要把灵魂卖给华为，要跟华为一起造车了。
那么另外一个就是捷暴鹿虎停产燃油车。
这也是目前豪华品牌第一个正式宣布停产燃油车的。
节目开始之前赵立还是做个通知。
京东的大墙子让我告诉大家，摆车悬说的粉丝为大家专属安排了618的红包。
即日起到6月21号在评论区的置顶的这条评论里面，去点击点击。
那么进入到主播专属的红包页面即可领取。
在京东的app里面你可以看得到红包。
下单的时候用红包的话，你就可以再优惠一点，是吧？
虽然不多，但是好歹是有那么个红包。
每天可以抽三次，通过每日打卡互动分享，
还可以有概率会领到大鹅的红包。
先领红包，后下单入口就在评论区。
好的，咱们先聊一聊马上拉地找华为虚命这个事。
那么这两天，七十圈应该算是个重磅消息了。
前两天微博也是上了热搜。
我看到很多同行也在讨论，有人开玩笑说，
五届之外是不是要多了一个新届，叫做马届。
就是马上拉地加华为，总是后面会带个届嘛，对吧？
那么叫马届，其实它不会叫马届的，我一会再解释。
那么马上拉地跟华为深度造册是以什么形式呢？
我们知道华为有很多种形式，比方说可以当。
零部件的供应商给你提供这个配件，
或者是像Arvita这种，就是说我是参与，
但是我不主导，我给你我的技术，
但是这个车还是在你的渠道里面卖，
你还是有一定的主导权。
那么第三种就是通过鸿蒙之行加入它整个体系里面，
那么就华为的门店也可以卖，
名字也正式的就是改为华为的什么戒，是吧？
那么它到底什么形式呢？
目前来讲的话，应该是第三种，
但是这个第三种形式，还跟之前有不太一样的地方，
怎么不一样呢？
就是一车两卖，什么叫一车两卖呢？
就是国内它是挂着尊介的标在卖，
国外是挂着马莎拉蒂的标在卖，
一句话就说清楚了，后面我们再展开。
那么这个消息虽然说官方还没有官宣，
就是两边，马莎拉蒂这边，
就是斯南蒂斯，
斯南蒂斯就是马莎拉蒂的相当于母公司嘛，
它没有去官宣，
然后华为这边或者说是鸿蒙之行这边，
或者说是叫车币U这边，
看这个好多名字，
它也没有官宣，
但是因为现在很多的主流平台都是在报道，
所以我估计就八九不离十，
而且往往像这种信息，
一般都是官方去到通过一些关系比较好的媒体，
让他们先提前透露出去，
要不然的话像这种事情肯定是要封锁的，
就是说它比方说我们只是开了一个会，
然后有一个会议备忘录，
像这种事情一般是不让往外漏的，
所以我估计主流媒体报道的那应该是八九不离十还是靠谱的，
那么这就意味着什么呢？
就意味着华为鸿蒙之行加上斯南蒂斯集团，
也就是它旗下的马莎拉蒂，
那么谁来造这个车呢？
就是江淮汽车在我们隔壁的兄弟省份安徽，
安徽去江淮的工厂里面造，
那么这个三方现在目前应该是我估计已经谈的差不多了，
就推进下一步的研发工作，
那么业内有相关人士推测说最快是二零二七年就有望量产落地，
这个就有点意思了，
我一会儿还是再讲一个也是斯南蒂斯起下的，
大家知道GIP对吧？
GIP它也是斯南蒂斯起下的，
但是现在卖的不是很好，
据说也要跟东风合作，
也是跟这个有点像，
然后把这个猛式的相关的技术直接放到了GIP车里面，
然后GIP就直接生产一个新能源的越野车，
一会儿我也展开来讲一下，
这个我觉得很有意思，
斯南蒂斯作为欧洲的也是非常大的一个车企了，
应该全球前几大了，
像这种车企现在在国内的这一套合作模式，
如果一旦能打通，
一旦要是能够起死回身，
让它原来在国内，
你想GIP这个品牌在国内都是二斤二出了，
对不对，是最早国产的豪华品牌，
或者说是越野车品牌，
然后后来又做不下去了，
然后后来又开始正式国产，
正式国产之后又做不下去了，
现在是两死两生，
现在它国内的国产车型基本上就停掉了，
就是只卖进口的，
像木马人这些车子了，
一会儿我们就聊这个的时候，
大家就能明白了，
就是马沙阿蒂为什么要这么玩，
GIP为什么要跟东风就这么玩，
所以我们先说马沙阿蒂，
马沙阿蒂其实说白了，
它跟江淮合不合作不重要，
关键它看的是华为，
那么在江淮这边去造车的话，
大家就很清楚了，
其实它是跟尊介大概率是贡献生产，
那么江淮跟华为是相当于，
就是共同合作的品牌叫尊介对吧，
目前华为五届当中尊介肯定是最贵的，
那么马沙阿蒂它现在是放在江淮去造，
然后用尊介这个标，
我觉得也能受得通，
那么今后他们两个人贡献生产，
那么相当于就不是说以前马沙阿蒂都是进口的吗，
相当于英国的老师傅手搓降人精神，
那现在就是安徽的老师傅去手搓，
安徽的老师傅降人精神，
这个故事到底最后怎么去吹，
怎么去包装，有待后期的观察，
就怎么让它能够更显价值，
这个就不是很清楚了，
但是比较有意思的一点就是，
据说这次马沙阿蒂跟华为的合作方式，
是华为主导产品定义，
就是这个产品怎么定义，
是华为来主导，
然后输出华为的智能坐舱，
智能驾驶，
还有电驱系统等等这些核心技术，
那么江淮是负责整车的研发和生产制造，
马沙阿蒂它只提供一个品牌，
还加上一个造型设计和底盘调教，
那么也就是这么停下来有可能会出现什么呢，
就是你今后会看到一辆车，
它就怎么看，它长的就像是马沙阿蒂，
但是挂着一个尊介的标，
会出现这么个情况，
这也是为什么我说，
它不会出现五届之外的第六届，
因为它已经很明确就是在江淮造，
已经很明确就是用江淮的尊介的标，
所以它不会出现第六届尊介，
只是用尊介的标，
然后马沙阿蒂的底盘调教设计跟品牌，
那么首先它放在尊介这个体系里面，
我觉得一辆车两个不同的标也没什么问题，
因为马沙阿蒂标它不会在国内卖，
所以这也是我讲它跟其他的这种合作形式不太一样的地方，
尊介的车子就是尊介的车子对吧，
它没有跟任何的海外车企去合作，
所以江淮造的尊介它即使卖到海外它就是尊介，
那么现在国内的马沙阿蒂的尊介卖到海外它就是马沙阿蒂，
但是在国内它就是尊介，
所以这里面就有一个悬念，
就这台车子我估猜大概率是按照马沙阿蒂的造型去设计的，
要不然到海外去你这个车长得不像马沙阿蒂，
老外不一定认啊，
虽然是新增援，对不对，
其实马沙阿蒂本质上来讲，
它就是希望你能造出一个新增援的马沙阿蒂，
而不是造出一个新增援的尊介，
然后挂一个马沙阿蒂的标，
那这个马沙阿蒂它也不太能够接受吗，
所以我估猜是以马沙阿蒂的造型为准，
然后是挂一个尊介的标在国内卖，
在海外去以马沙阿蒂的标来卖，
那么江淮来的话大家都知道，
马沙阿蒂在全球的知名度，
那就肯定是比尊介，
那甩它十条街都不止，
特别是在欧洲，
那欧洲人还是认的，
那这个再怎么讲，
这马沙阿蒂也是意大利超跑二王一后啊，
对吧，那二王是谁呢，
就是南伯基尼跟法拉利嘛，
那以后是谁，
以后就是马沙阿蒂啊，
就是马沙阿蒂我不知道它是有一点履性色彩，
还是说它更柔和一点，
但是我说句实在话，
我曾经在节目里面跨过很多次，
马沙阿蒂的这个声浪真的是太帅了，
非常的性感，
南伯基尼的声浪是非常的炸，
然后这个法拉利的声浪是非常的低沉，
但是这个马沙阿蒂的声浪就很柔和，
然后就是它柔和中还有一种爆发感，
那真的非常的舒服，
因为早年我非常好的兄弟也是我们卖他这辆车嘛，
虽然我卖奥迪，
但是身边的人比方说买超跑也会找我嘛，
马沙阿蒂GTMC，
当时带着我去中山林环林公路绕了一圈，
哇的天哪，开着车窗，
然后运动模式一脚油，
过去这个声浪的声音啊，
特别好听，
哇的天哪，
但是现在马沙阿蒂没声浪还能值几个钱，
我就在想这个问题，
对吧，它既是同车双标，
同车双标两个标在卖，
马沙阿蒂没声浪，
那用什么呢，
用这个模拟声浪，
模拟声浪这个虚假的声音，
说句实在话我是不喜欢啊，
所以还能值多少钱，
不知道，
但是这个同车双标的事情一听大家懂了，
是吧,
那么如果说按之前豪华品牌跟华为的合作方式，
那么大多数呢，
豪华品牌一般都不敢直接把华为整套的这个系统拿过来，
一般都是先，
比方说合作一个智能座舱，
或者合作一个智能驾驶，
你比方说奥迪，
奥迪说我跟华为合作，
这个智能驾驶对吧，
奥迪ASL有智能驾驶对吧，
奥迪已经和我们都陆续续的车都用上华为的支架，
而且它是非常谨慎，
它也不是上来全部都用，
你会发现你像比方说A4，
它就有专门的一个支架板，
ADS的版本，
最顶配的版本，
它也不是全部都给它铺集，
那么豪华品牌相当于只是跟它小范围的进行合作，
它还是比较谨慎的，
但是马沙阿蒂不一样，
马沙阿蒂这一次相当于是深度合作，
相当于上来就直接缩哈，
那为什么直接缩哈，
直接交出灵魂呢，
我个人觉得本质上来讲就是生存危机下的一个被迫自救，
那么马沙阿蒂现在已经都二年了，
已经一百多年了，
1914年,
现在是2026年，
112年,
那么马沙阿蒂呢，
112年超豪华这么一个品牌，
那么骨子里面其实还是比较傲气的，
说句实在话，
意大利的品牌都是比较傲气的，
2017年中国市场小量突破了5.1万辆，
这是它当时最辉煌的时刻，
对吧,
那么当时全球来讲的话，
中国市场也是它的最大单一市场，
那么随着电动化的转型，
可以说整个别说马沙阿蒂的，
就整个斯兰第四集团，
可以说是彻底失败，
那么销量也是断压式的下滑，
2025年马沙阿蒂在中国市场，
仅仅销售了1000多辆，
那么跟它巅峰时期比的话是暴跌了90%，
我曾经听讲说这个马沙阿蒂的品牌当时想独立出来，
什么意思呢，
就是马沙阿蒂一般都是跟法拉利的放在一起卖嘛，
他其实有段时间是不想跟他一个展厅了，
想单独列出来，
其实跟他一个展厅才能抬高自己的身家，
你开玩笑，
你马沙阿蒂单独列个展厅，
那你还能剩几个钱啊，
是不是，
所以当时马沙阿蒂第一个彻行不够多，
第二个我估计也是考虑到要转电动化，
所以就一直没分家，
分家我估计死得更快，
所以2025年整个市场就卖了1000多辆，
那么全球销量也是暴跌，
全球销量当时也就只剩7900多辆，
那么可以说是从2012年以来史上最低的一次销量，
母公司森兰蒂斯集团也是同连亏损了200多亿，
当时这个事情其实在网上也是个热搜啊，
也是个热搜，
当时他们就宣布，
就是说我们后面就不再去投入新能源这一块了，
所以这个消息当时是利好谁呢，
是利好零跑，
大家还记得吗，
零跑的股东之一就是森兰蒂斯，
所以你看森兰蒂斯旗下的剧谱跟东风合作，
然后马沙阿蒂现在是跟华为合作，
那其实他还有一个后手，
就是他直接入股了零跑，
所以这个公司虽然说他们自己不再投钱去研发什么新能源，
但他实际上跟中国的这些新能源车企绑的还是非常紧的，
所以说原来的像传统豪华品牌马沙阿蒂这种，
它的机械优势，
声浪的优势，
那么在智能电动化时基本上就彻底失效了，
你让大家再花个上百万去买个马沙阿蒂，
去听一听声浪，
现在声浪还值钱吗，
可能对一小部分人来讲还是值一点钱的，
那么提到马沙阿蒂的纯电设行，
这就更有意思了，
你能说出来拿几款，
其实在国内一共就那么三款，
有拿几款，
你能说都出来吗，
我估计最出名最出名，
就是大家可能张口就能说出来的，
就是那个叫格里咖喱，
就中文名叫格雷加，
格雷咖喱，
我不知道该怎么评那个英文，
吉尔伊斯雅尔伊格雷咖喱，
格雷咖喱，
格雷加这个车，
格雷加呢有一款纯电，
一开始也是默默无闻，
这个车是2024年上市的，
指导价是89.88万，
很多人一听到这个价格，
那就没兴趣了，
我管你什么品牌呢，
你纯电车让我花个八九十万，
老大真的是被抢挡了是吧，
那为什么他要订829.88万呢，
他估计自己也知道他卖不出去，
那么他订这个价格最根本的原因，
就是要对标隔壁的保时捷马刊，
马刊的纯电，
那么这个车呢当时为什么出名呢，
不是因为他对标保时捷有什么优势，
而是因为一年之后，
就是二五年的十一月份，
突然之间网上就传了一张海报，
说这个格雷加的纯电板啊，
裸车只要35.88万，
因为本身这个车子也交不了多少税嘛，
对吧，勾之税，
2025年的时候还是能免，
但是超了30万之后，
他还是要再交一点，
但交的不多嘛，
35.88万是裸车，
买个保险也没多少钱，
所以这个车子当时是值降54万，
那么很多的网友，
一开始以为是有人搞了个海报，
恶搞了一下，
那就不是真的，
但是结果有的人就好事的人打电话一问说，
这个是真的，是真事，
金销商相当于是打四折出售，
那你开玩笑，
马沙拉地卖30多万，
对吧，你就买这个标凹他也值这个价，
是不是，
所以很多人就开始去咨询了，
那么网上就传言说，
说是什么新店开业特批的价格，
是买断包销，
就是把整个这一批车买断了包销的，
所以当时我们也认为说，
那就是这批车说白了，
以后就不生产了嘛，
最后一批库存了嘛，
包销了嘛，
那么后来呢，
上海啊，
山东啊，
陈阳有一些金销商手上还有点存货，
也开始集体跟进，
那既然有一家甩卖了嘛，
那我就跟着一起甩，
也都是卖着30多万这个价格，
358800,
那么很多的网友，
就是这个自媒体啊，
当时觉得说，
哎,
这个好像是有流量的，
30多万买回来之后，
就把我把流量吃满了之后，
我再卖掉可能也亏不了几个钱，
所以就扛着摄像机就开始去买车了嘛，
网上出了很多的一些视频，
结果就发现短短的一周不到，
再去店里面就已经买不到了，
都是没车了，
那关键问题是什么，
这车不但现货如果没，
你订车也订不了，
为什么？
因为我前面说了嘛，
就是斯坦地斯已经明确，
不再去发展电动化了，
不再给马沙拉地去投资电动化，
所以这个车相当于就是最后一批，
倾库就退市了，
那么如果说用一句话，
去总结这个格雷加纯电短命的，
一年多吧，
就算是两年吧，
那么就叫做，
89万没人要，
35万不敢要，
你别看好像很多人去抢，
有些人是根本就不懂不了解，
还有一些我估计都是被自媒体给买掉了，
这台车子当时是什么一个技术参数呢？
400福的平台，
一听到400福卖800多万，
什么800多万，
400福卖820多万，
很多人就开始觉得，
2025年其实800福已经很普及了，
你随便买个可能230万的车，
就是800福的平台了，
它还是400福的，
然后关标续航CRTC是533公里，
所以这个实际我看到有一些，
虽然车主不多，
但网上也能查得到，
有些车主讲说这车实际续航很虚，
也就能跑个300多公里，400公里的样子，
那么车机也是比较反人类的，
因为它没有跟咱们国内的一些，
这种车机厂商去合作，
车机还是马上阿迪那套老车机，
然后关键是没有OTA，
就是你买来什么样，
今后就是什么样，
那么看完你就知道这个定价是非常的离谱，
就像苍苍鱼是80多万买了一台车，
然后只有可能30万左右的一个产品力，
30万可能我都说多了，
其中20万是品牌力，
有10万块钱产品，
然后智能驾驶的或者说智能坐舱的体验，
可能连10万块钱都到不了，
那么有人讲说，
说这个马沙拉地找华为属于是放下身段，
其实这个话我不认可，
这个话我不认可，
就是马沙拉地如果是在游车领域跟华为合作，
那我可以说它是放下身段，
但是马沙拉地如果是在新能源领域去跟华为合作，
那我觉得马沙拉地它这个品牌非但没有溢价，
甚至可能还是个累赘，
因为你游车领域我刚刚说了嘛，
就是二王一后它怎么说也是意大利的超跑品牌，
跟正苗红的就非常纯正的超跑品牌，
但是如果说你新能源领域，
你就是造个超跑，
你如果是纯电，
说实在话纯电超跑到目前为止，
我也没见过哪个车有多么的，
就是怎么讲的，
就是让大家觉得值得购买，
到目前为止没有，
那么此前国内有一些车企也会讲说什么灵魂论灵魂论，
其实灵魂论这个东西，
你看你怎么去理解，
就是说如果说你本身你这个产品是有灵魂的，
这个灵魂在市场上能卖出价，
那你说你把灵魂让给华为了，
那这个确实是，
这个叫灵魂论，
可是如果你现在你这个灵魂本身就不值钱，
你这产品力也没有了，
也没有人买单了对吧，
那你这个还要什么灵魂呢，
你活都活不下去的，
你这灵魂有啥意义啊，
灵魂是附在肉体上的，
你肉体就快被抛弃了，
你还有什么灵魂的，
是不是，
所以一开始有很多车企讲说灵魂论，
就担心什么核心技术被一些科技公司掌控，
失去产品的主导权，
但是对于马上阿蒂来讲，
油车的灵魂，
你别说马上阿蒂，
就是现在整个油车的灵魂已经没人买单了，
除非一些那种远处钢需车型，
要么就是车价格比较低，
就原来是卖个20万的，
现在卖个12、13万，
或者说是品牌是钢需，
就一直这个人就从来没开过BBA，
他现在要圆个梦，
买个奔驰买个宝马，
这个我觉得是没办法的，
他就是，
我觉得他不完全是冲着油车去的，
前者是冲着新加比去的，
是钢需去的，
后者是冲着他的品牌去的，
圆梦去的，
是吧,
那么电车的灵魂，
你说在一台油车或者是油车的品牌里面，
他能修炼得出来吗？
他能炼得出来吗？
他炼不出来啊，
所以对于这种，
所谓的什么百年豪华品牌而言，
我觉得他活不下去，
他在中国市场你想不想留下来挣钱，
你想留下来挣钱，
你目前的状态就是你活不下去，
活下去比所谓的灵魂是更重要的，
传统车企，
你说燃油车企，
他这个灵魂是什么，
发动机，
变速箱，底盘，机械调教，
那这些东西国产车确实做的没有海外这些车企好，
但是你电车时代的核心灵魂是什么，
是只能坐上只能驾驶，
是芯片是算法，
是不是，
那么这些你不是说马沙力的短板了，
是马沙力根本就没以后好吗，
几乎就没有吧，
就不能说完全没有，
几乎就没有，
但这些东西都是咱们国产的这些，
不管是车企也好，
还是像华为这种，
就是供应商也好，
都是他们的厂版，
就整个的中国的相当于是体系的优势，
那么对于马沙力来讲，
油车时代，
它的灵魂什么引擎，
伸浪，机械，操控，
意大利的设计，
品牌的标识这些东西，
那确实比不了，
就你看中国的油车时代就没人，
你比如说是造的好，
就没人敢造超跑，
谁敢造超跑，
30万以上的油车，
基本上国内就没人买了，
你国内虽然有一些销量，
但是国产车，油车，
那都是十几万的车，
能卖到二十万就不错了，
但是在电车时代就不一样了，
那不仅仅它现在，
讲究的是智能桌上智能驾驶，
续航补能，用车成本，
关键问题是它卖了上价，
对不对，
这个是对于他们来讲打击很大的，
海外这些品牌，
它现在二十万也有人买，
三十万也有人买，
五十万也有人买，
现在六十万的还是有人买，
那现在对于他们的这种豪华品牌的冲击力就非常大了，
你再往上走那不就上百万了吗，
对吧,
中国性能源是一步一步在往上走，
以前燃油车说要打造高端，
要突破高端天花板，
那突破了半天也突破不过去，
还是一个新制问题，
说句实在话，
就消费者的新制问题，
现在已经打通了，
你只要有一些黑科技，
你像我之前在节目里面，
有人讲我在吹理想，
又有什么吹不吹的呢，
800V你便宜的车你就是玩不到啊，
对不对，
UWB就是这一批车子先玩啊，
是不是，
然后最好的芯片，
目前最新的智能驾驶，
还智能坐舱，
还有那些大屏，
包括甚至于，
你想六座七座了，
二拍座椅的各种按摩啊，
通风啊，
SPA啊,
音响啊，
什么悬浮屏前后移动，
更换角度，
什么手势控制，
什么什么EC可调光，
那这些东西，
它确实只有五十六十万的车上有啊，
你想不想玩，
你想玩，
你在油车里你也买不到，
你在便宜的车上也买不到，
那你只能花五六十万，
它有这个钱，
它有这个预算，
它为什么不去消费呢，
对不对，
所以就这个逻辑非常清晰，
那你说以后啊，
技术再叠弹，
然后咱再给你整一些什么黑科技，
价格再往上提一提，
再往上提一提，
那不就上百万了吗，
是不是，
所以引擎昏明的时代已经落幕了，
不要再多想了，
智能化成为现在目前这个电车时代的新的核心竞争力，
它是一个话语权的替换，
我曾经节目里面讲过，
以前你说了算，
现在我说了算，
只要是触电，
在电这个领域，
就是咱们国内车企说了算，
你在全球都是这样，
只不过现在各种抵制嘛，
对吧,
有很多的一些国家不让进，
加税啊，
就是你除非跟我合作，
或者是把工厂落地这些东西，
我曾经也聊过，
所以马上阿滴为什么要拥抱华为啊，
这个就是它的一个底层逻辑嘛，
对于马上阿滴来讲，
你与其等着说被时代淘汰，
你等死呢，
不如就用品牌换技术，
你看品牌换技术，
现在它唯一值钱的就是品牌，
品牌就是它的资产，
品牌换技术，
灵魂交给华为，
那么对它来讲就是最现实的选择，
那说不定还能再挣一波钱，
你说是不是，
那不仅仅能在海外挣，
还能在国内挣，
所以我觉得，
今后如果说各大平台再去统计，
什么什么东风的销量啊，
红萌制情的销量啊，
你不要光是统计国内了，
现在都是换个标签，
直接出口到海外了，
你可以把这个销量全部算进来嘛，
你再去比一比嘛，
因为你这个销量说白了，
也是它挣的钱啊，
它就是换个马上阿蒂的标去国外卖，
它挣的钱还不进华为的口袋嘛，
获得进江淮的口袋嘛，
一回时啊，
是不是，
所以现在的这个销量统计有的时候，
我觉得还是有些bug的，
有人讲说那出口有单独的这个出口销量排行榜，
的确也是，
但是这个怎么讲呢，
就出口销量排行榜，
好像大家不是很重视，
其实我始终觉得现在的销量，
那你要如果这么加的话，
齐瑞很多车的销量，
国内加国外，
那排行榜上肯定是非常非常靠前的，
你如果是不加国外的销量的话，
那齐瑞的车在国内的销量，
我觉得就相对一般一点了，
是吧,
所以你看，
这马上阿蒂跟华为的合作，
虽然没足够官宣啊，
但这个事情我觉得比较有意思的点在于，
那么以前是欧洲这些车旗，
或者是欧美的车旗，
向国内去输出技术，
然后用它的这个品牌去做合资厂，
然后中国的车旗只负责代工进行生产，
对吧,
那么现在是变成中国开始输出技术和产品的定义，
然后在国内用你的标法而不之前，
那就用我自己的，
但是在国外，
那就用你的标去提供这个品牌的一价，
还有你的所谓的这个意大利的设计底运，
所以这种玩法，
我觉得也是至少目前来看前五古人，
后有没有来者就不知道了，
所以你今天来看这个事情，
我觉得除了华为之外，
那地平线啊，
英伟达啊，
那么这些第三方的智能方案商，
他们其实也在强势上，
他们比我们秀卷灵敏多了，
是不是，
他们现在叫做什么，
叫做违略传统车旗，
以前是盯着国内的这些车旗去违略，
所以跟什么北汽合作呀，
什么跟江湾合作呀，
现在你看，
海外的车旗也开始进来了，
而且它是主动找过来的，
不是我们仇爷爷高奶奶跟他谈个什么三个回合，
五个回合的，
人家是直接找过来谈，
说能不能我们一起合作一下，
国内呢用你的标，
国外用我的标，
所以这些第三方的厂商现在主打叫什么，
看这个什么，
凡人修行转都知道什么夺设夺设的是吧，
夺魂夺设，
它不夺魂，
用这种模式，
就你不要担心我，
我只提供芯片算法，
我不去掌控你的产品定义，
这些第三方是这样，
华为其实还是比较深度的，
所以它会给车旗留更多的主导权，
我们以前也讲过一个方案，
你比方说当年以色列的莫巴埃跟吉利合作，
它叫做黑箱交付，
它交付给你的智能压使的方案，
你不好去修改，
它只是给你一个结果，
如果说你要更新啊，
你说有些bug你要修改，
对不起意大利的工程师，
他们来去内部调试，
所以这种都是早期确实，
咱们国内起步没人那么早，
人家以前是搞军工的嘛，
所以它这一块跟你一喊，
但是咱们从零开始起步，
现在也不需要你了嘛，
而且你像这些第三方的，
包括像地平线，
包括像摩托塔，
它为什么摩托塔能跟那么多的一些车旗合作，
那车旗要求的是，
就不叫做黑箱交付了，
你要白河交付啊，
什么意思呢，
就是我要深度参与啊，
怎么样去运营你的这些算法策略的，
你可以留一点核心的技术，
就要老虎教猫不教你怎么上书，
不对，讲反了，
猫教老虎，
不教你怎么上书，
师父教会徒弟把师父给饿死了，
至少留那么一点，
但是绝大部分的我该教的还是教会你，
而且厂商他要留自己的主导权，
要能保持我的OTA的更新频率，
不能说你不更新了，
那我的车旗就一直OTA不更新了，
那我要能保持我的OTA的更新频率啊，
对吧,
所以对于马巴沙地来讲，
这种,
我可以讲说在燃油车时代，
已经算是冰冰淘汰的一个品牌了吧，
新能源转型几乎就是可以说，
一点收获都没有，
所以现在对于它来讲，
温和的方案是不足以救命的，
你只有跟华为这种叫做全战自研，
全战附能，
然后彻底去重构它的产品模式，
你才能短时间内迅速地去补起它的短板，
然后去重新回到主流市场，
是不是能回到真正的主流市场，
咱也不知道，
但是我觉得这么一操作，
你可以想象一下，
这么一操作，
一个长得像马沙阿蒂的车，
只不过挂着尊介的标，
对吧,
那我们不提倡啊，
但是一定有人肯定会去万能的淘宝，
去买一个马沙阿蒂的标给它换了，
但是你开到路上肯定是要被罚的，
这个我们不提倡啊，
这个应该算是违法了，
违章违法了啊，
为什么这个是违法，
就很简单，
你比方说，
万一要出了个车货，
然后结果这个车主招式逃逸了，
旁边一个路人讲说，
哎，我刚刚看到了那辆车，
车牌号没记住，
没记住，
但是我看到了身上马沙阿蒂，
结果满大街的去找马沙阿蒂找不到，
当然找这个车一定能找到，
但是,
那找马沙阿蒂肯定是第一往游车方向找对吧，
挂着绿牌也好找，
绿牌马沙阿蒂，
绿牌马沙阿蒂国内没有，
也有点意思，
反正这个标就是不能换，
但是一定有人为了装，
一定会去换，
为了带小姐姐什么的，
他一定会去换，
只要他长得像马沙阿蒂啊，
那么其实马沙阿蒂的这个选择，
也是给其他的豪华品牌，
可以说是打了个样，
打了个样，
什么意思呢，
就智能电动时代，
其实你就不要再想着说，
我这个品牌有多么高的溢价了，
对吧,
你要如果跟不上这个时代，
你新能源的转型如果失败，
那么你再去固守游车的红利，
你还能卖得出去，
你要奔驰宝马还能卖得出去，
那你去拥抱国内的这些新能源的厂商，
这些技术供应商，
你还可以稍微的，
怎么讲呢，
就是身价不用放的那么低，
就是浅长折执的去合作，
没问题，
但是像这种在游车时代，
它的红利几乎已经没有了，
新能源又是，
就是颗粒无收，
那对不起，
这种你哪怕就是百连品牌，
你没有用，
你在国内还是属于，
你就跌下神坛了嘛，
对吧,
所以就放下神段，
绑定顶尖的这些技术，
用品牌换生存，
这才是颇局之道嘛，
对吧,
那么对于消费者来讲的话，
其实我觉得是个好事，
为什么觉得是个好事呢，
就是马沙尔蒂给设计，
对吧,
底帮调教，
它还是有东西的嘛，
然后呢，
华为这边把相关的智能化的技术，
附能到这个车上，
这个车长的如果是像马沙尔蒂，
然后关键是看价格，
我不知道尊介这个价格到底最后怎么定啊，
就是你既能享受豪华品牌的设计，
那么又能享受国产顶尖的智能技术，
我觉得挺好歹，
最后就是看价格合不合理嘛，
你要如果说，
像格雷加这种类型，
我估猜最后是格雷加的造型，
直接换上尊介，
就是华为的那一套的车机智能坐舱，
然后智能驾驶，
再把那一系列的东西放进来，
哎呀,
你说一个格雷加如果换上华为的这一套东西，
卖多少钱呢，
还卖89.88万，
我觉得太夸张了吧，
如果说换上这样一套东西，
它最后就卖35.8万，
那我想问在座的各位你卖不卖，
格雷加大家上网可以去搜一下嘛，
大家可以上网搜一下，
马沙阿蒂的格雷加这个造型，
换上一整套的华为的这个，
智能坐舱智能驾驶，
华为的这个什么电区系统啊，
就是再给你整上林德时代的电池，
哎,
如果再搞个增尘，对吧，
纯电也有增尘也有，
就是两套动力，
让你去选卖个358800，
买不买，
评论区告诉我，
你买不买，
什么夺魂不夺魂啊，
马沙阿蒂的造型只不过尊介的标而已嘛，
是不是，
所以我感觉啊，
对于行业而言，
这也是中国制造向全球输出啊，
我觉得也是个标志性事件，
欧洲所谓的什么豪华品牌，
超豪品牌，
内心灵魂已经换成了中国魂，
开始说中国话了，
欧洲老外说中国话，
说不定这也有可能是，
撬动全球汽车产业变革的一个开始，
有可能，
对吧，有可能，
那么我们前面说了马沙阿蒂，
前面也提到了一个，
也是斯坦地斯旗下的一个品牌叫做GIP，
我们就简单聊一下吧，
GIP其实也是在用这种方式来验证这件事啊，
那么以前合资造车，
基本上就是外方出品牌，
出技术，
中方出市场，
让出市场，
然后出工厂，
出钱,
对吧,
其实市场换技术已经是很多年前了，
可能几十年前的这种说法了，
那GIP这次相当于是把这个GIP反过来演，
那么目前网上流传的信息是什么呢，
就是说GIP相当于是跟东风，
东风其实不止一家，
就东风联合了长江产业投资集团，
武汉金空，
还有武汉金开产投，
很多的一些中方资本，
他们加在一起是占了87%，
然后呢这个斯坦地斯，
他们这个集团呢是占到，
他们其实就投了1.3亿欧元，
只和人民币差不多应该是10.25亿，
那么总投资额是80亿嘛，
所以他们斯坦地斯只占了13%，
所以你可以理解为，
东风相当于这个边是绝对空谷，
绝对空谷主导权在中方手里面，
那么更关键是什么呢，
就是技术也不需要你外方过来教我，
那么东风呢他是输出性能源和智能化，
GIP的性能源车将来就是基于东风猛式的。
电动越野的架构来开发，
电机、电控、电池、智能坐舱、智能驾驶辅助这些，
都是他的核心的一些技术输出，
那么这些中方来提供，
斯坦地斯就跟刚刚我们前面讲，
马达阿蒂有点像，
他就是挂个GIP的标，
然后越野他也有点技术的抵运，
因为毕竟GIP品牌你开玩笑，
这老牌的，
所以他去负责越野的一些设计，
然后底盘调教，
越野性能调教，
然后关键就是他负责全球渠道，
就是东风在国内，
在国内我不知道他会不会挂GIP的标卖，
东风是当本市来卖，
我估计会卖，
因为这条信息我是没看到说一车双标的，
如果他不是一车双标，
那相当于就是GIP的店里面也可以卖纯电的，
或者是真诚的GIP，
然后旁边的猛式的店里面也可以卖个猛式，
结果两台车子可能造型不一样，
但是底子是一样的，
马上RD还不完全是一回事，
就马上RD跟尊敬还不完全是一回事，
所以说白了还是老套路，
对吧,
中国车企以前是跟外资，
外面的这些品牌去学发动机变速箱底盘技术，
老外也不怎么人人去教，
搞了半天，
中国的发动机变速箱也不咋地，
那么现在是老外的品牌在中国开始用中国的智能化来补课，
GIP我刚刚前面说了，
它是最早在国内国产的国外的品牌，
或者是豪华品牌，
但是之前广西菲克对吧，
那最后就是破产清算，
两次入华都破产清算了，
所以本质上它就是没跟上中国市场的一个新能源节奏，
或者说GIP我一直觉得它是一个不太接地气，
就是埋着头卖车也从来不管中国人到底要什么的，
这么一个品牌，
很不接地气，
我跟这品牌其实也接触过，
东西肯定是有东西的，
车其实也都还是比较好的车，
但是问题就是在于，
它的产品的更新也很慢，
更新换代的速度也很慢，
然后也不太会营销宣传，
手上其实还是有东西的，
但是就是它没有把它那种独特的味道给它体现出来，
其实买二线豪华的人，
它都是要求非常个性的，
都是非常个性的，
其实完完全全这几个品牌是可以把它做出来的，
不仅仅是GIP，
包括你什么克莱斯勒这些，
它其实完全是可以把它的个性化的东西给体现出来，
你不说能过的日子多好，
但是起码我觉得在二线豪华里面有那么一点自己的位置，
应该是不会有什么问题的，
但是没办法，
可能也是因为BBA也在降价，
BBA也在卷这个市场，
市场份额是如果时代太小，
那么对于像这些车起来讲，
有些车该停产就停产，
这边不更新，那边又停产，
那最后这个品牌就适能就没了嘛，
对吧,
那么好，
如果说GIP是一拖神龙的武汉工厂去生产，
然后再把车卖到欧洲，
卖到东南亚卖到南美市场，
那么它其实，
我觉得它的意义就不只是说这个品牌复活了，
它是中国技术借国际品牌出海了，
对吧,
这个就有点意思了，
就又跟马沙尔蒂很像了嘛，
所以你看GIP在全世界还是很认可的，
老外如果说现在能看到有一辆GIP是纯电板或者是增尘板，
然后旁边这个木马人是燃油板，
这老外可能心里面也会有点犹豫啊，
那我平时开着这个车也挺舒服的，
对不对，
然后我用起来也很经济，
你甚至于这个价格还便宜，
那你说它是买纯电的增尘的GIP，
还是去买一个燃油板的GIP呢？
哎，这个有点意思啊，
是不是GIP到最后，
他们可能也会思考这个问题，
就对它的品牌的伤害大不大，
包括它今天能跟你东风去合作，
你包括马沙尔蒂今天能跟华为去合作，
那有没有可能今后，
它去换其他的一些供应商呢？
因为它也不是唯一的呀，
它去换其他的供应商，
你不要说瑟莉安蒂本身就是跟林跑合作的，
哎，那它有没有可能说那能不能把林跑的这些技术。
附能到我的马沙尔蒂的这个骨子里面呢？
那毕竟那个林跑我是股东外，
所以说这个合作到最后到底能不能长久，
哎，你比方讲车币优，
说你瑟莉安蒂斯能不能入我的这个，
叫什么，
引旺对吧，
引旺公司，
因为它这个本身引旺公司现在就这么玩的嘛，
你比方说跟常安讲跟阿维塔讲说你你入股我，
你入股我，
那我们的合作模式，
就不相当于是什么老师跟学生的关系了，
或者就不是这种是供应商的关系了，
那我们俩相当于是合伙人，
那你瑟莉安蒂斯能不能，
哎，你也入股，
入到我的引旺的这个公司里面来，
你包括你比方说东峰，
那东峰跟他们成立一个新公司，
他们现在这个模式其实就相当于就是合伙了嘛，
啊，一起投钱嘛，一起合伙了嘛，
所以这里面我也是想问大家这个问题啊，
你说技术将来在国内卖的车子，
挂着技术的标，
造型也是技术的造型，
结果你就知道它其实骨子里面就是猛式，
啊，那你说它比猛式，
是要贵那么个五万块钱你能接受吗，
啊，如果价格一样的话，
你是不是买GPU去不买猛式了，
啊，或者说它要如果卖的比猛式还便宜，
那那猛式怎么卖啊，
你包括马上阿迪也是一个道理，
你会不会买，啊，纯电的，
真诚的，
好吧,
那么这个消息呢，
咱们就聊那么多啊，
那么现在又到了大家喜闻乐见的通知环节了啊，
其实大家都不喜欢买一家国高的产品，
那这就不得不提京东的618活动了，
京东大墙子让我通知一下大家，
给摆设全说的粉丝安排了专属的618红包，
即日起到6月21号，
在评论区点击置顶的链接，
进入到主播专属的红包页面领取就可以了，
虽然说这个红包不一定多啊，
但是肯定能用，
因为我看到评论区啊，
就是我在知识星球还有，
就是我看到群里面已经有很多人就晒出来说，
哎，三刀的红包我另了，
我最近正好下单，
然后虽然抵的不多啊，
可能抵了几块几十块的，
但这毕竟是钱啊，
你买杯奶茶喝那也是京东大墙子送你的，
是吧,
所以在京东的App里面你可以看到红包啊，
所以一定要记得看一眼这个红包的有效期，
每天可以抽三次，
每一次就是你每日打卡啊，
然后包括互动分享，
会有一定的概率获得更大额的红包，
先领红包后下单入口，
就在评论区，
那么好，
接下来我们聊一聊这个结报录虎，
成为首个停产燃油车的核子车企，
停产燃油车，
其实一直是个口号啊，
都要停，
大家都要停，
然后这个年限有的是2030年，
2029年反正都在喊，
但是真正有动作的，
现在目前来看还不是特别多，
大家都不敢停啊，
都不敢停，
就是你怎么着你也得保持一些纯燃油的产品，
然后呢，
因为它毕竟平台比较老了嘛，
对吧,
它这个成本摊销已经摊的差不多了，
价格卖的低，
它至少也能卖得出去，
卖一辆振一辆钱，
然后呢，
再慢慢的去过渡一下，
怎么过渡呢，
比方说往这个H1V，
就是不插电，
混沌上过渡，
最近不是开始有很多人在考虑说买H1V了吗，
几粒最近的H1V上的新车很多啊，
它就是陆续替代它的纯燃油嘛，
然后再去，
比方说往插混啊，
往增尘上一点一点的去转，
它有个比例，
有个过程，
那么纯停产燃油车，
而且是个豪瓦品牌，
那目前第一个付出时间的就是，
齐锐的捷报鹿虎，
大家也知道长熟嘛，
长熟齐锐捷报鹿虎嘛，
2026年3月31号，
最后一辆燃油板的鹿虎懒慎极光，
在长熟的基地下线了，
同时全新的电动品牌，
Free Nunder,。
也就是神行者，
就开始上市发布了，
就是品牌发布嘛，
那么这个盒子车企，
第一次全面关停燃油车，
这个其实真不多见，
其他的盒子车企也在喊，
但是也没去做，
其实完全关停，
我觉得是件好事，
因为你只要认准，
这个方向是对的，
然后呢，
你也下定决心了，
因为齐锐其实在行动员方面，
动作还是比较快的，
他这两年，
你看他那个截图，
其实卖的挺好的，
包括齐锐的车企，
现在也是在网行动员上去走，
所以齐锐捷报鹿虎，
相当于是提前上岸，
你也可以说他是被逼跳船，
提前上岸被逼跳船，
这个事情其实很简单，
前几年，
齐锐捷报鹿虎的整体的销量，
其实是非常的拉垮的，
非常的拉垮的，
就我们知道，
捷报鹿虎，
齐锐咱们不谈，
我们就讲捷报鹿虎，
捷报一直是一个很边缘的品牌，
鹿虎,
你想一想，
鹿虎其实现在国内生产的车，
卖的还行吗？
蓝圣极光，
什么发现运动，
卖的还行吗？
其实都很拉垮了现在，
捷报就更不用说了，
什么XE2、XF2、E-PACE这些,。
陆陆续续的，
基本上根本没人会想到去买这些车，
你都不知道他停产没停产，
2016年到2018年前后，
当时极光跟XF2卖的非常好，
那么这家公司当时相当于17年是高光时刻，
17年当时卖了8万多辆，
一年8万多辆，
对于这种品牌量很不错了，
那么再算上进口车型，
甚至他一年能超14万辆，
14万辆你想什么概念啊，
一个月卖1万多台，
所以在盒子品牌里面是稳稳的二线头户，
当时应该讲除了凯利拉克，
排第二的不是我，
我就是捷报鹿虎，
那么那个时候的整个市场格局很清晰，
一线就是本质宝马奥迪，
二线就是凯利拉克卧卧捷报鹿虎，
是不是，
那么随着2019年开始，
可以说是断牙式下滑，
19年负增长36%，
20年又降了8.5%，
然后稍微涨了一点，
2021年,
然后2022年又开始降3%，
2023年降8.7%,。
2024年降19%,。
2025年又开始降了22%，
然后是史上最低，
2025年的时候已经只能卖到一年2万多台车了，
你想想看，
2万,
从8万多台啊，
一路啊，
从17年到2025年8年，
就缩减了多少啊，
缩减了4分之3，
只剩4分之1的小量了，
所以说，
这个他卖不好，
其实很简单一个道理，
产品还是一个更新迭代比较慢，
第二个市场大环境变了，
大家都要行灯源，
他也不转，
他也不知道该怎么转，
捷报这边，
你想想看，
2026年的3月份，
就是今年的3月份，
它的XFR只卖了275辆车，
鹿虎那边卖的最好的，
就是极光，
极光当时就卖了625辆车，
我们就讲是国内生产的啊，
你说国内生产的这些车，
加载这两台车，
加一起都没超过1000辆，
所以就完全被边缘化，
那么进口这边捷报，
就基本上没什么进口车，
鹿虎这边的进口，
其实有两大主力车型，
大家都很熟悉，
一个就是蓝身，
还有一个就是卫视，
这两台车子，
那可是，
就是赚了老鼻子钱了，
这两台车子，
2025年的销量，
一个是16854，
一个是15827，
虽然说一年就卖1万多台，
但你要知道这是高利润车型啊，
而且是进口一辆卖一辆，
进口一辆赚一辆，
这里面我要提个醒啊，
就是进口，
这个接报鹿虎啊，
和国内的齐锐接报鹿虎，
这是两家公司，
是完全独立的两家公司，
所以那边进口的销量，
你不能算在齐锐接报鹿虎，
而且进口里面赚的钱，
也进不了齐锐接报鹿虎的公司的口袋，
所以说，
虽然说这个进口的两台车卖的好，
但是加在一起也就是3万多辆啊，
所以也不足以让齐锐接报鹿虎这个品牌能够再立起来，
那么还有一点就是，
也是更可怕的就是，
它国内这些车型，
生产的车型卖不出去，
那么就导致很多的经销商也撑不下去了嘛，
所以经销商数量在急剧减少，
那目前来讲在网上我们查了一下，
也查不到说，
它现在到底还剩多少家经销商，
反正我知道在南京那边，
好像就剩那么一两家了吧，
然后这一两家也是举步为奸，
那之前有粉丝想买车，
我也是问了一下，
我感觉他们整体的效率也不是特别高，
可能就能在这个时间点还能留在捷报鹿虎的，
我估计这些销售也是以养老为主了，
对吧,
就是到这个公司黄了，
我再换下一家，
对吧,
我却这么混着，
就当养老，
家里面可能也不差钱，
哈哈哈哈，
那么目前来讲的话，
他们产品更新节奏也很慢，
然后动不动这个车也要停产，
那个车也要停产，
捷报这边插一二插一二，
那多少年没换贷已经不知道了，
就没人去关心了，
品牌声量也是持续下降，
他现在已经算不上是什么二线豪华品牌了，
就是二线豪华日子已经很难过了，
已经没有人再去提他说什么还是三线还是几线了，
他现在就是个小透明嘛，
对不对，
那么为什么现在他会成为首个直接停产燃油车的豪华品牌，
我觉得第一层原因很简单，
就是他的整体的定位是比较模糊的，
他早期其实捷报鹿虎是很想对标BBA的，
鹿虎其实是有点看不上BBA的，
最早年鹿虎的这些车主确确实实是高于BBA，
有点跟保时捷的这种感觉有点像，
但是捷报他一直定位都比较的模糊，
无论是品牌溢价还是产品力，
我觉得都不够支撑他这个价格，
那么在全球范围内其实大家我觉得不止中国人，
老外应该也是这么认为的，
就是你这么多年也不去更新，
也没什么拿得出手的技术，
你就一直是设计设计设计，
但是那两年捷报的设计好看吗，
越来越工业化，
就完全没有以前英伦车的那种雪茄车身那种骚气的感觉，
对吧,
我也不讲究车内的空间有多少，
但只要帅就完了，
帅就完了，
当年雪茄车身多帅啊，
我当年我卖过融为750，
大家还记得吗，
然后还有包括明爵MG7，
到现在还有很多人去二车市场想去讨一辆MG7，
讨完之后，
然后自己去再把它翻新一下，
改一下，
帅了一塌糊涂啊，
那个橘黄色的夜景仪表，
哇,
漂亮,
真漂亮，
那不是夜景仪表，
就橘黄色的主驾驶仪表，
机械仪表，
那还不是夜景仪表，
那么同时，
捷报鹿虎的内部，
其实现在也是非常尴尬，
我前面也讲了嘛，
就是他们也是转型失败嘛，
纯电转型失败，
也没掀起什么大风大浪，
燃油车这边也基本上就是该停的就停了，
想换又换不了代了，
然后鹿虎这边品牌力虽然稍微强一点，
但是核心车型就是我们前面讲的，
懒胜懒运卫视，
懒运也是卖的一般般，
就是懒胜卖的好，
最旗舰的，
最顶的，
然后卫视卖的好，
对吧,
那定位那么高端，
也没多少人去买，
现在整个国内的消费也是，
大家都懂的，
对吧,
懂的懂的懂的，
就是消费有钱人也不敢乱花钱啊，
所以换句话讲，
对于齐锐捷报鹿虎，
其实它旗下没有一个能打的，
真的没有一个能打的，
这是第一层原因，
第二层原因是什么，
就中国市场本身现在大的趋势已经在变了，
你想想看新能源的渗透率，
从2020年,
也就是5%左右，
到2023年,
就直接飙升到30%，
2024年40%,。
2025年50%,。
今年2026年，
我看到业内的预测到年底，
能够接近60%，
就是保守估计也是55%以上，
所以这意味着什么，
就是燃油车现在基本上已经靠不住了，
那么对于这种二线豪华品牌，
还想靠燃油车吃饭，
很难,
非常难，
上面想靠燃油车吃饭的很多呀，
BBA也想靠，
BBA现在也在往下乘，
现在BBA,
你看奔驰宝马今年1月份、2月份，
全在官宣，
直接一口价，
直接关降，
上面在往下压，
他们品牌力更强，
用户更稳定，
下面往上顶，
下面是国产新能源，
智能化也很强，
更新速度也很快，
你说像捷暴路户这种，
既打不过上面的，
也压不住下面的，
那怎么弄啊？
所以齐瑞捷暴路户，
你说它是主动转型，
也不完全准确，
它有点像直接跳船了嘛，
它不转没机会了，
最后一张船票，
你再不上船，
上中国的这艘船，
你就淹死在海里面了，
第三层原因是什么，
第三层原因就是，
它其实也能看得出来，
现在基本上盒子模式也在变，
我们之前讲的盒子模式，
以前是中方需要外方的品牌和技术，
但是你拿它过来，
这些,
有人讲说中方就是买办嘛，
老外说教你教你，
教那么多年也没教会，
它也没认真教，
但是现在不需要你外方的品牌和技术了，
品牌可能还要，
不需要你的技术了，
中方有自己的这一套体系，
情德冤技术给到你，
那你外方你还能生什么，
你还有什么能跟我谈，
你的资本，
是不是，
这盒子的方式现在也要变，
那有人讲说，
齐瑞捷报路虎，
它本来就是一个盒子公司啊，
对吧,
那这个盒子公司，
难道说，
现在齐瑞接手了，
哎,
你说对了，
以前在卖游车那个年代，
还是路虎跟捷报那边，
话语权比较大，
但是现在，
这一次的官宣啊，
就是直接Frelander，
就是出现一个新品牌，
单身之后啊，
那么停产燃油车，
转新能源，
对不起，
从今往后，
中方说了算，
就是中方说了算，
停掉外方的主导权，
回归中方的话语权，
你想新能源实在是什么特点，
要快啊，
你们这些老外，
燃油车迟迟都不更新，
不换贷，
那,
你齐瑞能说什么呢，
说白了，
就是给你把这个车给它造出来，
经销商网络，
那还能干什么呢，
它干不了什么事儿，
啊,
国产现在新能源品牌，
动不动一年一更新，
两年一换贷，
甚至一年一换贷，
一年更三贷，
我的天呐，
那你海外这些盒子品牌，
你能跟得上吗，
你跟不上啊，
你还转个，
转个啥新能源啊，
你燃油车你也跟不上啊，
你都跟不上，
所以,
外方,
你不能说完全是外方的原因，
就是,
外方跟中方盒子公司，
它,
就一直会处在这样的一个问题点，
以前没有新能源的时候，
三年五年换个带，
无所谓，
反正,
对吧,
躺着挣钱，
就是捷报路虎，
还是有人买的，
现在这个话语体系，
这种,
怎么讲的，
造车的这种，
逻辑,
已经完全不做效了，
完全不做效了，
其实,
就是捷报路虎的新能源转型，
在,
传统和挖品牌里面，
还算比较早，
捷报是2018年，
你想想看，
18年,
8年前,
就已经推了当时的纯电车型ipace，
其实ipace当时非常不成功，
而且,
我当时看到海外的照回也很多，
国内因为卖的特别少，
所以没有掀起什么风浪，
当时这个负面，
如果出来的话，
其实,
它可能很早就已经要结束了，
然后,
这次齐锐捷报路虎呢，
当时就学聪明了，
发布了全新的电动化品牌，
叫菲兰的神星者，
那么,
我刚刚前面也说了，
就是外方，
你现在还能主导什么呢？
你最多就是主导一下设计，
外观,
按照你路虎的造型，
我们保持不要有一些造的不像路虎，
对吧,
中方就是主导技术跟运营嘛，
常属这个基地，
其实已经砸了30亿了，
那么新能源的智能化产线改造，
对吧,
那么未来五年，
它是会去投，
差不多六款车型，
差点是混合动力，
纯电,
增程,
三种路线都有，
其实不就是，
齐锐的那一套东西嘛，
就是截图上的那套东西嘛，
有纯电，
有增程，
有查回，
一听就明白了嘛，
所以将来其实都是底子，
全国内的这些，
车企这些品牌提供的，
然后呢就换各种不同样的，
海外的这些标，
GIF的标,
马沙拉蒂的标，
截爆路虎的标，
所以以后你再去买这些，
核子品牌的新的原车，
你只要一看，
你就回头稍微上网，
搜一搜，
它到底跟谁合作，
你就问一下，
这个品牌跟谁合作，
不是有很多AI嘛，
你一问，
你再去找一找那些，
型的相关的技术，
你可能会发现车机，
比如说这个截爆路虎，
就跟骑瑞的很像，
然后呢这个马沙拉蒂的这个，
哎就是华为的，
这也不用遮着眼着，
都知道的华为那一套，
HOME OS,。
对不对，
GIF那边就是东风那一套的，
猛盛那一套系统，
所以呢这种玩法，
我觉得也挺好，
就是神星者，
就这个品牌，
Free NANDER将来要是诞生之后啊，
它的模式主要就是有三个特点，
第一个，
它不压库存，
第二个呢就是，
销售，交付，售后，
它就是全售全了，
然后金腰商会相对少，
但是门店会很多，
这什么意思呢，
就是它商场里面也开，
然后到处开，
就是它会把它的这个销售网点开的特别密，
然后最后统一在一个地方进行交付，
这不就是现在行政员的这个模式吗，
甚至可能它售后网点也是统一的，
一个城市有那么一个点两个点，
交付也是有那么一个点两个点，
那么我们再回到之前的问题，
你说它是商案了，
还是跳船了呢，
其实我觉得两者都有，
它就是说，
现在这些盒子品牌，
或者说这些海外的车企，
它已经看清楚了，
就是这个大趋势已经不可立了，
而且在目前这个当下活下去，
比什么交灵魂更加的重要，
所以说它就只能做出这样的选择，
行吧,
今天就聊了那么多，
今天聊的我觉得信息点还是比较满的，
从马沙地啊到GP啊，
然后再到我们讲的齐锐杰宝鹿虎，
信息呢我们整合的也是花了很多时间，
其实这个稿子很有意思，
一开始是齐锐杰宝鹿虎停产载油车，
传谣啊，就是摩老师写了一篇稿子，
然后我一直没发，
一直没发，然后传谣就催我，
说就是刀哥你找个机会，
赶紧把这一篇给发了，
后来呢，
哎,
后来我看到说这个马沙阿蒂的这个事情，
跟华为合作正好是个新闻热点，
我就把它穿插进来了，
那么写着写着呢，
我就突然又收很多信息，
我又收到说，
哎,
GP又跟东风合作，
就不也是斯坦利斯集团的嘛，
所以我就把三篇整合到一起了，
所以一起分享给大家，
节目呢，就是闲聊天，
有人讲说啊，
我还是喜欢听三刀的，
就粗重量道胡说八道，
哎,
怎么讲呢，
就十几年了，
所以说实话，
该胡说八道的时候会胡说八道的，
该这个，
我们就是，
吃点细凉，
也要吃点细凉对吧，
你不能吃粗凉吃惯了，
就吃不，
吃不了这个细凉，
有的时候我们去整理一些数据，
你要上一期节目，
我们去整理一些干货信息，
啊,
讲什么超人玻璃达，
好米玻璃达，
什么激光离达固态的，
什么可变交的，
说不听不听不听，
不聊不聊不聊，
这个我觉得也能理解，
有些人就是说，
买车就是买个情绪价值嘛，
对吧,
这些所谓的这些什么，
硬件信息啊，
技术参数，
我就不爱去了解它，
我了解它干嘛呢，
但是有的人爱听，
评论区里面我看到了，
也有人会讲说，
哎,
给我确实补了很多的一些信息上的盲区，
所以呢，
就是,
做自己想做的，
觉得这个事情是正确的，
往个大方向去走就可以了，
我现在也想明白了，
包括今年，
其实整体市场是比较齐惨的，
里面看今年新车特别多，
自媒体这一块，
其实今年整体，
我不能说不挣钱，
就是今年整体，
下滑非常严重，
非常非常严重，
真的,
所以有些自媒体，
你看到现在很多微博上的自媒体，
出去都旅游去了，
你它为什么现在动不动，
它们出去旅游啊，
没活啊，
它不像我还有固定更新，
你像我的音频节目，
还有周三周六更新，
然后B站是每周更一期，
然后抖音那边也是一直保持，
隔日更啊，
反正动不动就更，
那我的微博也是每天都在更新，
所以我很多的事情要做，
那我是没有这种感觉，
说我要可以度个假了，
我没有上单，
我就可以出去玩了，
不是这样的，
但是现在有一些那种，
如果平时没有日常更新的，
那不去参加活动了，
就直接出去旅游了，
就是今年特别惨淡，
惨淡也能理解，
因为今年上半年，
整体的车企的销量也很惨，
所以它的投放也很惨，
所以你看这边又没什么收入进来，
然后那边又被网友骂说三刀啊，
你最近广告特别多啊，
各种充值，
其实不是的，
就是如果说我这场节目，
这个这个专题他是充值的合作的，
我的语音语调和节奏都完全不一样，
老听友一听就明白了，
那这个就不需要去解释了，
对吧,
那有人就不费就是觉得，
就是这个节目里面聊这款车，
你优点是远大于他的缺点，
你缺点几乎就没怎么说，
但是这个产品本质上来讲，
我觉得就还行啊，
没什么问题啊，
而且提到了一些改进的点，
我是以改进的方式，
我觉得这个地方可以再优化一下，
那我这么去讲，
你要如果去忽略，
那我也没什么办法，
对不对，
那你喜欢听的可能是上来就劈头盖脸一顿喷，
就这个不行，
那个不行的很刺激，
对吧,
那的确我也刺激过呀，
我在微博上也发过很刺激的言论啊，
那不是被封号分了七天吗，
对吧,
那我在喜马拉雅这边，
我也不知道我说了啥，
我也不是被封了七天嘛，
对吧,
那这是第一次是七天啊，
你再往后呢，
15天30天,
再往后180天，
再往后呢，
永久封号，
那好了，
那我们从此就说再见了，
那是不是因为这个我就不敢说呢，
那说还照说啊，
只不过现在是这样的，
就是你如果是验证过，
你不是张口就来，
你不要说我测出来，
他的续航就是350，
我可以拿出实锤的证据，
你随便怎么说，
没人能够掰得到你，
没人办得到你，
但如果说你只是作为一个市场行情分析，
或者我主观的去判断，
我们微博上那个经常主观判断那个人，
到现在还没被放出来呢，
对吧,
这一直被封制呢，
他都就是像主观嘛，
都是主观，
那主观到最后对不起，
现在的互联网不一定，
第一个不一定有人愿意听你主观的观点，
第二个，
主观,
你认为主观，
那我也可以主观上去，
对吧,
给你动一动这个，
让你动一动你的这个，
对吧,
这个你皮有点松了嘛，
我让你紧一紧，
哈哈哈哈，
行啊,
这就是闲聊天吧，
就是节目最后就闲聊天吧，
那么每期节目呢，
我们会抽三位，
赠送由人言计提供的苹果翠两包，
非常好吃，
老人孩子都爱吃啊，
那么大家想买也可以上我的小程序，
摆车全说，
进行下单，
也不要忘了啊，
我们这个京东的红包真的是，
真的是有用的，
如果你要在京东去购物的话，
评论区至顶的链接，
可以去直接点击，
像小宇宙的话点不了，
你只要复制到游览器里面打开就可以了，
领完之后，
看看他的有效器，
然后再下单，
非常好用，
好,
那么接下来呢，
关于上期节目的留言互动，
车上的这些传感器给大家解释了一遍，
那么第一位叫做麦贤鱼的老默，
他说,
哎呀,
刀割这期节目太理科了，
我听不懂，
我也不想听那么多，
他说真不如刀割，
你就随便聊点生活事，
身边事，
然后呢，
汽车新闻什么的，
你给我们讲一讲，
都可以，
哎,
怎么讲呢，
其实这么做，
反而更轻松，
那我不就是想做点有意义的事情吗，
但是你要这么一说，
我觉得也挺好的，
那汽车全新闻，
直接给他解读一下，
也很快啊，
我觉得每个月确实，
每个月我们有八期节目，
可以分那么一两期，
月头月尾，
做一个汽车圈新闻解读，
然后呢，
中间再来一个留言互动解读，
然后再来一个这个销量盘点，
就已经四期节目就，
我而活了嘛，
对吧,
那么剩下来几期，
我再做几个选题，
再把我平时试过的车，
拿出来讲一讲，
哎,
一个月八期，
轻轻松松就结束了，
是不是，
但是我，
我也不知道为什么，
我总是觉得，
可能我对内容还是有点追求啊，
大家讲一讲，
你是想听新闻解读，
销量解读，
想听听聊一聊身边事，
跟车完全不关的，
能结束吗？
可能有些人又说不结束，
跑题了，
好,
我们再看下一条留言，
这位ID叫做，
焦唱军，
他说,
道哥啊，
我是知识星球的老粉丝，
但是我在平台上，
这是第一次留言啊，
5月20号,
520早上骑电动车上班，
前车为了躲避横穿机动车，
飞机动车的这个老大爷，
急杀,
然后我也急杀，
没杀住，
结果躲上了前车，
把自己的车给撞烂了，
它是电动车，
这不是汽车，
我看他发了个照片嘛，
确实,
因为那个特名交代给他连起来了，
他说我的车壳撞烂了，
结果老大爷还在那边骂骂，
我呢,
自认倒霉，
确实是我的问题啊，
因为什么呢，
因为,
他说我第一个是疲劳，
他们家刚升娃，
所以晚上这个带娃，
所以,
就一直没睡好，
第二个呢，
就注意力不集中，
这个我也要提醒大家啊，
他是一边骑车，
一边带着耳机，
他在听这个罗勇号，
跟理想的第二次访谈，
所以他可能会，
老子里面在思考一些问题，
反应速度会慢一点，
第三就是他的这个速度，
可能会稍微快一点，
导致一下没杀住，
我估猜，
我看他那个车子是9号吗，
我感觉是9号，
他那个车子肯定是，
破了线速的，
肯定是破了线速的，
几个问题，
加在一起，
结果破费了350块钱啊，
修了个车350，
还算好，
老大爷没受伤，
他也没受伤，
他说我当天下午全身酸软，
疲劳,
没精神，
不出所料，
晚上开始发烧，
他说道哥能不能，
送几颗玉露香梨，
让我补一补元气，
所以你就不是铁粉，
你节目肯定没听完，
上期节目开始，
就已经送的不是玉露香梨了，
送的是这个苹果翠，
好吧,
你吃吃苹果翠，
躺到床上休息休息，
也能补补元气，
对吧,
苹果补元气也挺好的，
一天一苹果，
就一身远离我，
好,
下面一位听友叫做胡鸣壮壮，
他说道哥，
哎,
我就领了好几张京东卷，
然后叠加plus会员给优惠，
真的合适得很，
感谢,
非常感谢，
感谢大家支持啊，
非常感谢大家支持，
今年其实整体来讲的话，
这个音频这一块儿，
我觉得是稳中向好，
咨询的这个科发挺多的，
也是因为就是去年这个老罗的十字路口，
把这个整个播客稍微带火了一点，
那么再加上我这边呢，
其实也是跟国内现在有一些不可联盟，
就是也是老元啊，
这个西军佛他们，
我想每次去北京，
会跟他们联系一起坐下来聊聊天，
就是中国人之间啊，
就你想做生意，
你要社交，
大家在一起交流交流啊，
聊一聊啊，
互通有无啊，
就比方说我们情怀归情怀，
对吧,
生意归生意，
交流完之后有效果的，
还是有效果的，
那回来之后就会发现，
他们在这边也会帮你去推一些业务，
然后我这边有些想法跟他们沟通，
有的时候往往有些商业合作还是能推进的，
但是今年整体呢，
我觉得对于我们这种小团队来讲，
我说点真心话啊，
我们在南京有好有坏，
好处是什么呢，
就是我们整体的成本比较低，
不管是这个公司的办公成本也好，
还是说我们整体的人员开销，
因为你想你在北京生活成本很高的，
你每个人你没有个高工资，
你根本不可能在在在你这个小公司里面干着的，
所以你想要有好的人才，
你想要出好的内容，
那你其实是成本是非常高，
所以你不要看有一些自媒体好像说内容拍的还不错，
然后你感觉它的更新频率有点慢，
你觉得它的这个什么剪辑很厉害，
或者说是稿子写的很好，
那你要去想一想它请这么好的一个，
如果说不是它本人写，
它请了这么好的一个编导，
请了这么好的一个后期，
它得花多少钱？
那这个成本真的是非常难估量的，
而且说句实在话，
这个成本它是要叠加的，
你今年第一年是这个价，
明年可不是这个价了，
你包括像商务，
就包括像我们做自媒体的这种小公司来讲的话，
商务也是非常核心的，
那商务在我们圈内经常也会有跳槽的，
那一跳槽就把这个公司可以说可能。
20%、30%的客户直接带走了，
那这个老板只能亲自上证啊，
再去挨个刷脸，
刷完脸之后再慢慢的去，
对吧，恢复一下自己的客户关系，
所以自媒体其实我，
你有人讲说我在抱怨什么的，
其实我也不是抱怨，
就是咱们在做这件事情的时候，
情怀是归情怀，
深意是归深意，
两件事情我是分得比较开的，
我是真的很喜欢做内容，
但是我也很喜欢赚钱，
大家也不用去估猜说，
三到二你这几年挣到钱没有挣到多少钱，
就怎么说呢，
钱肯定是这样的，
要不挣到钱怎么可能还有这么个小团队，
十来个人围着一起去做内容呢，
但是我一直是比较保守的，
就是不那么突进，
所以内容呢，
就不愧说像大家想的说，
那么的博人眼球，
那么的去想要短时间内去，
长粉KPR指标特别的好看，
所以呢如果说，
哎，跟了我这么多年了，
大家觉得说这个风格，
三到一直没怎么变，
对吧,
虽然这个节目呢，
可能质量奇奇怪浮浮，
有的话题你爱听，
有的不爱听，
但是整体来讲，
如果你把我当个朋友，
当个兄弟，
就不离不弃吧，
想起我的时候过来听听我的节目，
好的,
最后先聊一小会，
就聊那么多吧，
以上就是本期节目所有的内容，
给大家收听啊，
如果想看看我的视频，
Bilibili搜索摆车全说，
短视频账号呢，
像小红书视频号抖音快手，
搜索三刀砍车，
单人旁砍大山的砍，
还有就是我的个人微博，
摆车全说三刀，
每天都会更新，
还有我们公众号，
摆车全说，
想要进社群也可以加微信，
4641-5254,。
今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下期接着聊，
拜拜!